uh during the riots Lightfoot was like
hey yeah it's only property let them
destroy it but when the protesters start
moving towards her house she had a
district sites Police Department
blockade her whole block to protect
her oh the mayor the mayor
[Music]
okay I'm gonna tell you guys a story
about something that just happened in uh
Bell town near uh Seattle this might
have happened in Seattle but it's about
uh a woman and a man Aina Kwan and
sunquan they're the owners of aburia
Bento house there's a restaurant in
Belltown right they're uh they're at a
red light surveillance video shows this
they're stopped at a red light in their
Tesla
for absolutely no reason at all a guy
just walks up to the window and just and
just shoots uh four shots into Anaconda
woman oh my God in the head and then
shoots through the arm of song Quan so
as that happens there's a guy nearby his
name's Randy and I believe he's like a
he may be like an off-duty kind of first
responder kind of guy so he like sees it
he runs over he tries to help he has
some like gauze and um
the The Man Song is pleading with him to
help save her so they both like uh try
to put pressure on the wound on her head
the dude doesn't even realize he's had
his arm like shut up but uh by the time
the paramedics arrived she wasn't
breathing anymore
and uh yeah she didn't make it they get
her to the hospital and she where she
passed away turned out she was pregnant
oh one of these why you why why you give
stories like this so sad and then at the
hospital they were able to do an
emergency C-section and the babies oh
wow but the baby didn't make it oh gosh
why you do that again the baby died
after they got the baby out and then
they just got a shipment of a puppy that
day and then the puppy because they
didn't go home and a tornado came and
the puppies suffocated in the Box
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah it's a the tornado threw the puppy
into orbit
the shooter turned out to be this man
named Cordell goosby who is a guy living
in a homeless and cabinet right by that
area he admitted to the murder and said
he shot at them because he thought they
had a gun
so he's just like a random crazy guy
fell into fell in from Illinois and he
his firearm was reported stolen from the
Lakewood area in in the Washington yeah
so it almost has every single feature of
things that
it's almost like the perfect storm of
everything that goes wrong from the law
like in a weird way it's like why wasn't
he
like he got through every single like
hoop to end up right next to unlucky
people that were unsuspecting and that
had their lives pretty good and ended
prematurely by something just like freak
happening you know what's funny uh it's
not funny uh but it's frustrating when I
was a cop was I've arrested many people
with felony records that could have been
a novel ugh right uh murders that could
have been prevented
things that could have been prevented if
the justice system did their job we
arrest them we do our job we write the
report we get them booked they go in
there they go in the revolving door they
come back right back out yep and it's
constantly like that and it's
frustrating as [__] for us because we're
like man I'm busting my ass I'm putting
my life on the line dealing with these
4X felons 5x felons but they know
they're gonna get out
like that could have been prevented yeah
he's a felon for whatever he caused he
could have spent more time in jail or
done that more time in jail he could
have spent would have altered that time
where that car would have went away that
he would never yeah that's why you ever
heard the saying like when you're doing
this type of job it always pays his
spend that split seconds to tell your
loved ones I love you or kiss them
because that Split Second might have
changed your life from being killed you
know and with this and everything else
damn that's heavy are my our Buddy's a
sheriff and he was saying like recently
it's been so weird where he you know he
he he has a warrant on these guys he
grabs them and then
um the prosecutor won't actually do
anything is that happening
Nationwide oh yeah this happens all the
time or like is this a new Phenom like
new thing or like it was like they were
actually Prosecuting before he said but
now they're not or like so when you
elect your D.A district attorney they're
they're he or she is the one that lays
down the letter of the law of like hey
we need to prosecute this x criminal
make sure they stay behind bars or they
can be lenient about it and be like hey
if it's this crime this crime this crime
uh no we're not going to charge them
we're going to let them free or we're
gonna bump it down I had so many
attorneys States attorneys where we came
with a like letter of the law followed
the law that this is a felon oh you know
we're not going to charge them with a
felon we're going to bump it down to a a
misdemeanor
and I'm just like what's what's the
motivation to do that why would I do
this I'm wondering why it's happening in
so many cities at the same time what
what's the what's the benefit to because
I've always why do they want to do that
I you know what it beats a shot at me
sometimes I scratch my head too you know
I was like don't you want to prosecute
these people so they can understand like
hey if I commit these crimes I'm gonna
pay by doing time or like really getting
punished a lot of these people they know
like oh I'm gonna do this crime I'm
gonna come back up is there a benefit to
their personal political careers oh 100
so that's what it mostly is what would
what would that be that like their lower
crime rate there's some people enjoy it
more when they do that like the stats of
criminal's being released like yeah like
why would D.A wanna
show like lesser or not process does
that like rig the numbers at the end but
they go look during my time here yeah we
had less questions 100 oh so recently
um I think L.A times or whatever just
posted that Ellie's about to go into a
zero bail policy so so like if someone
gets booked that night
they're getting let go that day there's
not even a half bail Chicago has some
something similar too like if you if
it's this crime this crime this crime
this crime and it's something [__]
crazy too like something that you should
be spending jail for they'll let you
right back up yeah what's that
conspiracy time yeah you know I'm really
into this [__] yeah yeah you have a
question oh no you go ahead I was gonna
ask about mayor Lightfoot so what I
recently found out is some landlords
back in the day like Tower like in town
so New York they have uh rent control
right certain buildings before the years
1950 or whatever I don't know the actual
year yeah they have a lot of tenants
that pay cheap rent and they wouldn't
leave or whatever right so what these
building landlords would do back in the
day is basically they would get hookers
they would get homeless people they
would just let them stay and then
they'll do the work of like destroying
and scaring all the tenants and then the
if the tenants didn't want to leave
because they're protesting and trying to
like form a HOA and just be like [__]
you landlord we're gonna stay then they
made it extremely disgusting and
uncomfortable for those people to want
to stay and also the buildings would be
crumbled and [__] up remember like
when we watched all those old movies in
New York where like all of the buildings
were boarded up and all that it's
because those buildings were so like
um rent controlled that they couldn't
make enough profit to actually make
adjustments like to fix it or whatever
so they just left it Rock to rot and
then so my theory is that these they're
doing it at a city-wide level so like
what if you want cheap real estate but
it's expensive
you want to create
low uh value by making it a shitty
neighborhood deliberately
lots of crime people get scared they
move out they they sell their property
they're like I don't want to be here
anymore it drives the price down you
know a city like LA or any major city is
going to go up eventually right so you
just buy it up buy it up big companies
come in and then
you clean it up
you know what I mean you have your own
team the DA's whatever you finally start
putting money back into the police force
and then you just
I don't know that's my that's my take on
it you think it's the politicians want
to buy up in their own neighborhoods so
they I don't think it's politicians I
think they're being hired by like let's
say BlackRock uh like let's say like
major corporations corporations that
play the game yeah I don't know because
there's a you know there's conspiracies
like uh like George well it's not even a
conspiracy because proven but George
Soros destroyed uh Argentina's economy
and he was betting on that and he made
money and it's like it's like [__] like
games that are so high level that we
don't even know you know
super powerful and Rich player I believe
it
but I don't know I don't have no
evidence right that's just my take on it
like that could be the case like why
would someone want to [__] up their own
City so hard because I'm also like it's
so hard to turn a city around like how
do they
if once how did they make it where the
property values do go up because cities
once they turn to [__] they generally
stay shitty for a long long time yeah to
even turn around anyways well when we
were kids in the uh you know the 80s and
90s La was a [__] like cars on
burning you know trash cans and then
they turned it around and then they sold
all this property like in the 2000s so I
don't know
maybe they're just doing the cycle again
that would be really scary if that's
like they're playing whatever purposely
yeah yeah that's the game dude dirty it
up clean it up dirty it up clean it up
but it does it does always make it so
confusing as to what the real like if
it's not that yeah then the motivation
to just keep going easy on criminals is
so hard to figure out what is The
Logical point of this guy like beat up
three people tonight I bring them in and
then I let them go I know know that when
I read liberal art like like heavily
liberal arguments about it they do bring
up a lot of things about how like no
incarceration just makes criminals worse
and makes more criminals so they want to
look to uh where are they getting
alternative ways of corrective yeah but
there's that time aspect that Trump's
talking about where if they were had
they just been put away even for three
nights yeah that's three nights of peace
for the civilians yeah like that that
that coupled in the Tesla had that
person yeah already shot other people if
they've been doing their time that's
other couples that they wouldn't have
shot that's what the hurts to me the
most is how like you have like a couple
of honest people that their whole lives
they've been by the book they do
everything like to a good standard and
yet they still have to watch out for
just the random death that might happen
at the hands of some person everybody
loves Theory until it hits their block
yeah yeah you know what I mean like oh
yeah let's do this but make sure it
stays in that neighborhood let's say
let's let's say if that happened oh yeah
let's let's do that let's not lock these
criminals up let them stay in your
neighborhood yeah yeah you know let it
let them let them run rampant in your
neighborhood see how fast that'll turn
around where you'll be like okay we need
to arrest these people that's what the
key is they don't let them run in yeah
you know what's funny though I keep
compared to the right thing because it's
[__] crazy because we I see in
firsthand being a cop uh during the
riots like foot was like hey yeah it's
only property let them destroy it but
when the protesters start moving towards
her house she had a district sized
Police Department blockade her whole
block to protect
that's two times you've said it
foreign